my name is Ron Mahurin I'm the vice
president for professional development
and research with the Council for
Christian colleges and universities
we're based in Washington DC as I travel
the campuses one of my opening lines is
hi I'm Ron Mahurin I'm from Washington
and I'm here to help ya it's about the
kind of response I usually get I'm very
privileged to to chair this panel for
the next 90 minutes on economics and
immigration and before I introduce our
first speaker just a word about the
council so those of you who are our
friends alumni of Hillsdale County
College the council is an association of
Christian colleges and universities
about a hundred and eighteen members
here in North America and another sixty
affiliate members in 30 nations around
the world and we're very pleased to be
part of this program and partnership
with Hillsdale in the act and Institute
to bring resources to faculty teaching
in business economics history political
science and related fields on on the
free market this morning our panel is
entitled economics and immigration we
have three presenters and I'll introduce
each of them in the order that they will
speak this morning
I want to note at the outset that as the
title suggests the focus of this session
is on economics and immigration no doubt
during the question and answer session
our interests may run beyond the simple
notions of economics and immigration not
so simple it's a very complex topic but
our speakers this morning will be
focused primarily on that relationship
between economics and immigration so if
you have questions that you'd like to to
address to the panel we'll have time at
the at the last half-hour of our session
our first speaker this morning is a
faculty member at Hillsdale College dr.
emporia sniff a kaliya t' hillsdale as
an associate professor of politics in
2008 that follows his work in in
political science at the University of
Dallas where he received his degree in
2006 dr. Porteous has previously taught
at Belmont Abbey College near Charlotte
North Carolina and Mountain View College
in Dallas Texas he is a frequent speaker
at Hillsdale College's Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
in Washington DC just a few blocks from
our offices and he teaches and has
research interests in American political
thought and American political
institutions
he writes online for the Washington
Times human events and big
government.com and Kevin tells us that
he is currently working on a manuscript
on the framers of the Constitution Kevin
Porteous
good morning thank you all very much I
have a confession to make after the last
panel I'm not an economist and I'm not
even I'm not even a mainstream political
scientist so many of your institutions
you know what the political scientists
look like they're it turns out I'm not
one of those either which is to say I'm
part of a program that has no math
requirement so there's there's no
quantitative research going on in the
Hillsdale College politics department
when we look at a policy or a policy
issue as I was asked to do here in the
case of immigration my first reaction my
first impulse is to say fair enough what
are our first principles what are we
starting from and so that's the way I'd
like to approach talking about
immigration in the political thought and
in the the policy decisions made by
America's founding fathers by the time
President Bush gave his address on
immigration in 2006 and sort of opened
up the modern incarnation of this can of
worms it had become much more of an
issue obviously than he then he thought
it would become I think somewhat to his
astonishment and over the course of the
past half-dozen years America's founding
fathers have proven a somewhat fruitful
field for those looking for support for
their positions so for example Alex now
Ritesh and I'm sure I'm butchering that
name and I apologize from the
Competitive Enterprise Institute
commented on the first immigration law
made under the Constitution in 1790 that
it quote had zero restrictions on
immigration you read that right the
first immigration law in the United
States by the founders themselves
supported open immigration on the other
hand Thomas woods who's the author of
nullification among other books and the
politically incorrect guide to American
history writes that quote in fact the
founding fathers were by and large
skeptics on immigration citing Jefferson
Alexander Hamilton George Washington
Rufus King and others
and the reality I think is that there's
truth in both of those statements and
that's a hard thing to say at the end at
the outset right we have two people who
take opposite positions and there's
truth in both positions okay well it's
gonna take a political scientist to make
any sense of that right but no no the
reality is is somewhat more complex but
at the same time I think that once we
start to unpack it we see that that the
founders had a view of immigration
that's helpful to us in trying to sort
out our own problems
so I said that we were going to start
with first principles and if we're gonna
go back to first principles there's
probably no place better to go than the
American Declaration of Independence so
in that document the signers argue that
under the laws of nature and of nature's
God all men are created equal it's we
quality under the law equality of
natural rights equality of obligations
under the law and the political
corollary of that equality principle is
the principle of consent the idea that
no one has an inherent right to rule
somebody else nor does anyone else have
an inherent obligation to submit to the
rule of anybody else so Jefferson very
famously noted that the mass of mankind
has not been born with saddles on their
backs nor a favored few booted and
spurred ready to ride them legitimately
by the grace of God so political
obligation for America's founding
fathers was the consequence of the
voluntary consent of the individuals who
lived in that society and this is a big
deal is something I try and explain to
my students this this was huge for them
to say in 1776 because they had come out
of a system the English traditional
system and the traditional understanding
of citizenship was based on feudal
obligation and what that meant was if
you were born in a particular place you
were a subject of that place as
sovereign for life in decel you bleed
their was nothing you could rightfully
do that would break that connection with
your sovereign so if you were born on
British soil you were a British citizen
for life
and this view was very cogently
expressed by by Blackstone who says that
natural allegiance is such as his do
from all men born within the King's
Dominion's immediately upon their birth
for immediately upon their birth they're
under the Kings protection for it is a
principle of universal law the
natural-born subject of one prince
cannot by any act of his own no not by
swearing allegiance to another put off
or discharged his natural allegiance to
the former and so the principle embodied
the principle of consent embodied in the
declaration stands directly opposite to
that it's the principle that Jefferson
who articulated a couple of years
earlier in his very famous essay a
summary view of the rights of British
America where he says that in coming to
the colonies what are now the colonies
the original settlers exercise the right
which is given to all men by nature of
leaving the place of their origin and
going to a place of their choosing this
is a radical rejection of the
traditional English system you are not
bound to a particular place you are not
a citizen by birth and this
understanding of Jefferson's was the
understanding that infused the drafting
of the Constitution and American law for
decades so today we very commonly assume
that the Constitution includes something
that we now refer to as birthright
citizenship now that was not in reality
part of American law until ninth 1898
when the Supreme Court in the case wah
Wonka mark versus United States decided
that citizenship was determined by birth
in other words we have returned in a
very significant way to the old feudal
understanding of citizenship where your
citizenship is determinate determined by
the land in which you are born now I
want to be very careful in making my
second point the right to leave the
place of your origin and settle
someplace else is not the same thing as
to say that you have a right to go to
any other place of your choosing and
settle there
that's a different story so the right to
leave at one place does not constitute
at the same time the right to enter
another place listen to what the the
people of Massachusetts said in their
1780 Constitution for instance the body
politic they write is formed by
voluntary association of individuals it
is a social compact by which the whole
people covenants with each citizen and
each citizen with the whole people that
all shall be governed by certain laws
for the common good and what they're
telling us is that in order for a system
to truly be consensual in order for the
principle of consent to operate and for
people to be treated as true equals
consent must be mutual and reciprocal
that is to say everyone must agree to
live under the society but the society
must also agree to take in each
individual who seeks to live under that
society the governor Morris declared in
the Constitutional Convention that every
society from a great nation down to a
club has the right of declaring the
conditions on which new members should
be admitted so consent has to work in
both in both directions to say otherwise
is to violate that principle of equality
so if a person can come to the United
States or any other country for that
matter and settle in that country and
become a part of that political
community in contravention of the laws
of that country then he is in effect
declaring to that country I am your
superior I will set the terms of the
contract and impose them upon you it
would be the equivalent of my arriving
at your house declaring that I like it
handing you an unspecified sum of money
and moving in you have to agree to the
contract just like I do in order for the
contract to be valid and in order for
equality to be preserved under the
consent principle and this doctrine or
this understanding in their mind implied
no violation of the rights of the party
who was denied admittance so by refusing
to allow a person to enter into the
United States or again any other
country we are not denying that person
of any right he still has the right to
go anywhere that will take him or to go
to some unoccupied place and establish
himself there and to take whatever
measures he deems to be necessary and
appropriate for the security of his
rights and so Madison had a very
interesting interpretation in the
Federalist Papers what do we do about
the states who don't ratify the
Constitution this was a very real
problem at the time because at least two
states had decided at the least
temporarily no we don't wish to do that
Rhode Island and North Carolina and so
Madison says while we can't compel them
and in the absence of their free ascent
we fall back on the law of nations
they're a sovereign independent nation
and we have to treat them with the
respect and and justice that should be
accorded by any nation to any other okay
so so we have then the right to leave
but not necessarily the right to go
wherever one pleases and this takes me
to my third point which is not only does
a nation have a right to place
restrictions on who enters the country
who becomes a member of that political
community but under the right
circumstances
there may also be an obligation to do so
this becomes apparent when we think
about founders first principles in terms
of not just the consent of the governed
but why do we have government in the
first place and if you go back to the
declaration the declaration says to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men so not only do we
have to have government by the consent
of the government but we also have to
have government that protects people's
rights so crucial to having a government
that protects people's rights is having
a citizenry that believes that people
have rights and that supports a regime
that tries to protect those rights
Washington told the Hebrew Congregation
in Newport Rhode Island that citizenship
is not a free gift of Rights without
responsibilities that the United States
requires quote that they who live under
its protection should demean themselves
as good citizens in giving it on all
occasions their effectual support they
have to support those principles and a
major part of that is having the kind of
character that inclines them to support
those principles so in Virginia's
Declaration of Rights in 1776 which was
authored by George Mason and served as
an inspiration for Jefferson in drafting
the Declaration he says at the very end
that no free government and I'm quoting
now or the blessings of liberty can be
preserved to any people but by a firm
adherence to justice
moderation temperance frugality and
virtue and by frequent recurrence two
fundamental principles a people which
doesn't have that character will be
incapable of asserting their rights when
they're threatened and living with
others in peace and that's a major
problem for a country that seeks to
protect rights now this applies to
immigrants as well so Jefferson wondered
if immigrants would be able to adopt our
principles and his point was where are
many immigrants coming from well they're
coming from places that don't
necessarily respect rights so if you
grow up in Soviet Russia for instance
the regime doesn't teach you stand up
for your rights speak out against the
government right see Siberia and all of
its wonders okay that's not what you
learn in Stalinist Russia shut up keep
your head down do what you're told that
of course is a problem Americans need to
be vigilant in asserting their rights
but they also need to know what the
proper boundaries of those rights are
and most regimes don't teach that don't
imbibe that into their citizens and so
like I said that creates a major problem
so having no experience with no wonder
no real understanding of Liberty it will
be difficult for immigrants to conduct
themselves in a manner befitting a free
citizen of a republic they'll either
continue in their previous mode of
civility or being released from all
controls for the first time we'll move
in precisely the opposite direction
now this is interesting because at the
same time that Jefferson and others
expressed profound concern about the
character of immigrants they also have a
very distinct sense that America should
be an asylum for oppressed peoples
around the world they did not believe
excuse me the belief that America is
such a refuge did not begin with Emma
Lazarus in the new Colossus a very
famous poem that's on me on the Statue
of Liberty Washington declared in the
1780s that he had always hoped that this
land might become a safe and agreeable
asylum to the virtuous and persecuted
part of mankind to whatever nation they
might belong and so when it came time
for them to make public policy decisions
they had to try and balance those two
elements in their thought which is we
need to preserve the character of the
regime in order to protect the rights of
our citizens but there's also this
American exceptionalism which says we
want the virtuous and oppressed of the
world to come here see this as a haven
for them and to make the country better
so what did they do as a practical
matter as a policy matter well initially
the Articles of Confederation said
nothing about citizenship except that
states would decide the citizenship
issue and this created a number of
problems because people would go to
states with low citizenship requirements
and then under the Articles of
Confederation other states were bound to
accept the citizenship of that person
who'd come in to an easy state to enter
into so created some conflict so when it
when the the clause in the Constitution
that talks about a uniform rule of
naturalization is proposed it's referred
to several times and it sails through
the convention without comment or debate
the idea that we should have one rule
for for immigration for naturalization
now with what else isn't what what else
is interesting in this regard is they
really didn't place any restrictions on
entering into the country but they did
place restrictions on citizenship which
is of course a key difference when you
are a citizen you are an active member
of a political community you have a
share of rule and if we go back to
Aristotle's very famous maxim of ruling
and being ruled in
erm you are a part of that rule the
primary requirement for citizenship was
of course a residency requirement which
varied throughout the time period two
years five years fourteen years finally
back to the five years that we know
today so on the one hand they didn't
place any restrictions on entering into
the country on the other hand they gave
no substantial incentives to come to the
country the basic position was expressed
by Benjamin Franklin with regard to
encouragement for strangers from
government they are really only water
derived from good laws and Liberty
unquote so America is a place he goes on
to say where noble birth doesn't matter
and there isn't this massive surplus of
useless government jobs to be filled as
this great laugh line today right
there's no useless government jobs out
there well in 1782 when he wrote that
there weren't there were very few
government jobs his thought was and the
thought expressed by Washington
Jefferson and others was the opportunity
to labor freely in a land where honest
labor is honorable would be incentive
enough for the type of person that we
wanted industrious and virtuous alright
as far as the statistics and get into
the numbers a little bit even though I
don't teach any mathematics one of the
difficulties is there really aren't any
the US Census Bureau did not keep track
of immigration until 1820 so for the
purposes of looking at the 1780 1790s
there really isn't very much to go on
however the very commonly used estimate
for the period the quarter century
beginning in 1790 is about 250,000 and
these primarily overwhelmingly came from
Northwest Europe so a few from France
but also Switzerland Germany especially
the Rhine and Palatine provinces the
Netherlands Britain and Ireland
so where do we end up as a policy
position I don't think it's fair then to
say that well the founder supported open
borders or the founders supported
restriction ISM not sure that those are
entirely accurate into and of themselves
at the same time that Jefferson worried
about the character of immigrants and
the character of the regime he said
quote if they come of themselves they
are entitled to all the rights of
citizenship again this is a position
that was reiterated frequently the
practical policy that they encouraged
was one of assimilation that is to say
becoming part of the new regime becoming
part of the order to which they had
emigrated and this was to be facilitated
by dispersion of immigrants among the
population Washington for instance was
very concerned about immigrants settling
in one very collected not in a
particular place where they would retain
their knowledge habits customs etc and
the adoption of the English language now
this idea of assimilation is embodied in
their 1795 immigration law which
included an oath and in that oath a new
citizen was required to swear an open
court that he quote death absolutely and
entirely renounce and abjure all
Allegiance and fidelity to every prince
potentate State or sovereignty whatever
and particularly by name the prince
potentate State or sovereignty whereof
he was a citizen or subject before in
other words no dual citizenship one
sovereign one nation and so on so
assimilation worked then but what about
now I would suggest in conclusion that
there are a couple of varying a couple
of factors at work here immigration was
fairly low but there were also periods
of rest when those who had come to the
country could assimilate I think the
other problem the other difference with
today's immigration is people in the
1780s 90s early 18th century were very
committed to America's first principles
that is to say you came to an
environment as an immigrant that was
rich with belief in ideas of liberty and
equality and government by consent and
justice and all of these things that are
espoused in these numerous documents
like the deck
independence I would suggest that that's
not necessarily the case today
understatement of the century right
fundamentally however is that a problem
with those who come to this country or
is it a problem with us and so in
conclusion I would say that the key from
from my perspective to understanding the
immigration problem today is for
Americans to re-adopt those original
principles as the best guide to their
politics and policy thank you very much
our second speaker this morning is Miss
Sica Dahlia who is senior policy analyst
at The Reason Foundation Dahlia is a
columnist at the Daily America's first
iPad newspaper and writes regularly for
Reason magazine she is also a frequent
contributor to the op-ed pages of The
Wall Street Journal and other
publications such as the Los Angeles
Times the New York Post the Weekly
Standard and the Chicago Tribune she
previously served as a columnist for
Forbes
Dalmiya was the co-winner of the first
2009 Bastiat Prize on for online
journalism for her columns in both
Forbes and reason she has served as an
award-winning editorial writer at the
Detroit News she worked as a reporter
for the Patriot a national daily
newspaper based in New Delhi India where
she grew up and earned her BS degree in
chemistry and biology from the
University of Delhi she also holds a
master's degree in mass communication
from Louisiana State University so if
you've been paying attention here she's
covered the map quite well she is a
frequent guest on Fox Business Network
and other television and radio outlets
and lives in the Detroit area with her
husband and son the title of her address
is the economic case for open borders
Sika Dahlia
thank you Ron well Kevin mentioned the
different character of immigrants who
can come to the country today well you
know I'm an immigrant came here 25 years
ago and came here partly for economic
opportunities and partly because I love
this country and what it stands for and
I think there are many many immigrants
who are just like me who come over here
both for the opportunities and the
principles that this country stands for
but we worry about everywhere new wave
of immigrants that comes here and this
has been as Kevin pointed out going on
since the time of the independence and
the Declaration of Independence but
every wave of immigrants brings with it
all kinds of concerns I'm not here to
talk about the cultural aspects of
immigrants today I'm going to focus and
you know concentrate my remarks on the
economics of immigration and it's a
little bit ironic that I'm talking about
the economics of immigration because
there are plenty of economists in this
room much better qualified than me and
so if you have any questions about the
economics of immigration please direct
them to them after the immigration is a
very very strange issue it's a subject
of a lot of popular fear and political
debate but there is a great deal of
consensus among economists that
immigration in fact is a very great
blessing
what's more this consensus not only cuts
across political lines it also cuts
across methodological lines with
classical liberal neoclassical Chicago
School Austrian school and even some
Keynesian economists agreeing that
unfettered relatively unfettered labor
mobility maximizes economic growth Adam
Smith a more opposed mercantilist
restrictions not just on capital but on
labor as well Ludwig von Mises the Guru
of the Austrian school advocated a
system of free trade where capital and
labor would be employed
wherever conditions were most favorable
for production
there was one prominent exception to all
these economists and his name was Karl
Marx you might have heard of him
although he didn't treat the subject in
any systematic way his passing comments
here in the air suggests that he was no
fan of immigration for he for example he
regarded England's decision to absorb
the surplus Irish Irishmen being driven
out of their country during the Great
Famine as a ploy by the English
bourgeoisie to force down wages and
lower the material and moral position of
English working class the popular modern
day restriction is preneur that
immigration from the third world to rich
countries is tantamount to importing
poverty has its genesis in Marx's
thought indeed far from being
embarrassed by this lineage restriction
is actually touted I will quote mr.
Krekorian himself he said in one of his
papers employer organizations spend
enormous resources lobbying the
government to import a reserve army of
labour to use Marxist phrase so that
they can hold down their labour costs
and avoid unionization it is ironic that
according to polls these days half of
the public of the free world including
in America this land of immigrants sides
not with free market economists like
Adam Smith and Ludwig von Mises but Marx
the father of socialism the primary
reason for this is that the case for
open borders is in fact quite
counterintuitive it is hard to see how
in a world of finite resources allowing
more people into the country would
enhance its prosperity you know it's
very common I mean it's it seems natural
to us that somehow more people there's
more overcrowding there's more job
competition and there are lower wages
but this Malthusian worldview I'm going
to argue is actually dangerously flawed
I will lay out the theoretical case for
open borders and I will discuss some of
the empirical evidence although you will
have to go to my full paper to see a
parsing of the academic literature
showing you know why immigration is a
net boon according to economic
and finally I'll address the most common
restriction asturian to open borders the
issue of the welfare state but first
let's just discuss what does one mean by
open borders for most advocates it does
not mean that anyone should be allowed
into the country no questions asked
what it does mean is that immigration
should be based on the real
socio-economic needs of a country's
residents not the arbitrary whims of
bureaucrats or the grand designs of
social planners this implies that the
government has a legitimate role in
keeping all foreigners who pose a
genuine public health or safety threat
to the people but other than that it
shouldn't be up to the government to
decide under such a system employers and
individuals would be able to apply to
the government to bring in a foreigner
the government could accept or reject
their application based on whether they
pose a security threat or not or a
public health threat but barring that
entry would be allowed in other words in
a properly constructed immigration
system there would be a presumption for
liberty built into our immigration
policies that would just that would
require the government to justify to its
citizens why they can't bring in some
foreigner into the country not the other
way around not the citizens who would
have to justify to the government but
the best way to describe our current
system the way it stands is there is
effectively a ban on immigration which
is then selectively relaxed based on
some bureaucratic categories or some
social planning ideas so for instance
found a family reunification these days
is encouraged ethnic diversity which we
were not in favor of for almost three
decades from 1930 to 1965 is now what we
want we want ethnic diversity and the
upshot of this kind of immigration
policy is that when Bill Gates he waits
years to be able to hire a Chinese
computer engineer or a California farmer
who can't hire anybody on a permanent
from Mexico dangerous individuals are
constantly slipping in through the
cracks this is not a system that's
conducive for freedom or safety or the
rule of law it virtually invites
lawlessness even as it wastes billions
of dollars in border busting in
budget-busting border controls so what
is the theoretical case for immigration
or open borders or economic case at the
heart of the economic debate about
immigration stands this fundamental
disagreement restriction is see human
beings as a liability who deplete
resources non restriction is see humans
as an asset who themselves are a
resource indeed they are the ultimate
resource as Julian Simon said human
ingenuity and hard work turns fallow
land bounteous dirt into valuable metals
and sand into computer chips
there is no given or fixed set of
natural resources out there so
assignment pointed out useless materials
become become recent become a resource
once human creativity creativity is used
to turn them such oil was just a toxic
black liquid in the ground it's human
discovered that they could burn it for
energy the development of high-yield
grain increased the productivity of land
exponentially while human population
grew only arithmetically the exact
opposite of what Matthews had predicted
the most important factor limiting a
country's economic progress then isn't
insufficient physical resources but
insufficient human resources
hence contrary to Malthusian thinking
population increases through immigration
are nothing to fret over incidentally
there it's not a coincidence that
modern-day restriction lists are also
population restriction esteem stanton
the founder of the federation for a mag
american immigration reform based in
michigan he is actually the grandfather
of a lot of restriction is outfits
around the country he was also a member
of zero population growth club that
advocates a national population policy
that would limit child birth
but immigrants are not only mouths who
need to be fed but also minds and hands
who grow the economic by the consume
resources for sure but they produce far
more than they consume over the long run
in fact to the extent that immigrants in
this country whether they are high
skilled or low-skilled a completely
bureaucratic distinction it's because
they produce more in value or wealth for
their employers than they consume
otherwise they would be of no value they
wouldn't have jobs
everyone would regard it as colossal
estupid if America dispatched missiles
to shoot down foreign planes that were
periodically air dropping free goods on
American homes yet why is it not equally
foolish when it shoes away the source of
this wealth namely Mexicans who sweat
puts cheap goods in our homes or when it
turns away Chinese computer engineers
who are virtually spitting gold from
sand restriction estar gyu that ending
mass my great emigration and creating a
scarcity of labor would force industries
to invest in labor saving technologies
that would drive even more productivity
and growth but if an artificial scarcity
in labor is such a great thing why not
of other resources as well imagine how
many more high-yield grain varieties
would be generated if the government old
farmers that they can't form on half of
their land the fallacy in this reasoning
is that it ignores the opportunity costs
forcing producers to search for
technological substitutes for cheap
immigrant labor
mis allocates precious time capital and
energy that could have been deployed for
all kinds of other inventions open trade
and goods we all agrees allows physical
resources to flow where they can be
deployed most productively likewise open
trade in labor allows human resources
even more crucial and physical resources
to flow where they can be deployed most
productively and increased productivity
is a win-win for all there is plenty of
empirical evidence that testifies to
this no one would dispute I believe not
even mr. kerkorian that open immigration
policies would be a huge equal
McCune for immigrants from relatively
less well-off countries the huddled
masses that Kevin was talking about
indeed a Guatemalan increases his wages
six-fold for the same work simply by
stepping foot on American soil if the 30
OECD countries were to allow 3 percent
rise in the size of their labor force
the world the world's poor would go
again 300 billion dollars and that's the
currently the OECD countries our entire
foreign aid budget is 230 billion
dollars immigration in fact is the best
aid policy
now of course rich countries do not have
a moral obligation to fight global
poverty however they do have a moral
obligation to maximize the economic
well-being of their citizens or at least
not prevent their set-aside citizens
from maximizing their own economic
well-being pursuing their own happiness
as Jefferson put it so let's just
examine the benefits of immigration for
Americans themselves in this land of
immigrants economists unanimously agree
that immigrants increased native
earnings at least to the tune of twenty
two billion dollars in to two thousand
and three dollars even Harvard
University is Georges poor Hoss the
favorite economist of restriction asti's
that immigrants on the whole briefs the
wheels of the US economy because they
are far more mobile than the native
population quickly moving where their
skills are most needed
now everybody also include agrees
outside of restriction is circles that
high-skilled foreigners are an
unmitigated economic blessing even mr.
Boerhaave thinks that that would be a
good idea that's because their
innovations and high-tech
entrepreneurship are vital in an
advanced knowledge economy they create
high-paying jobs raise native wages and
they contribute much more to public
coffers than they actually consume in
welfare the real controversy is really
only about the impact of low-skilled
grunts but again the controversy is more
mostly in the political realm among
economists there is a great deal of
consensus that even these ik immigrants
are a net economic asset let me just
give you a personal story that'll
illustrate some of the broader points
that are covered in the vast economic or
academic literature on this issue I have
a house with a rather large yard in
Michigan some five years ago after
struggling with weeds and pests and on
the verge of really doing permanent
damage to my back I finally gave up my
husband and I at that point renewed our
search for an affordable yard
maintenance which we had not till then
been able to find because yard
maintenance is just expensive in
Michigan we finally found once one
company that could or one actually small
business owner who could provide us
affordable service and he was an Iraqi
we'll call him Jacob why could Jacob
offer us a better price because he had
somehow managed to find some slow
skilled Mexicans a very rare commodity
in Michigan by the way - could you know
whom he could offer cheaper wages over a
period of time Jacobs business has has
expanded and now he includes commercial
businesses as well he caters to
commercial businesses as well as
homeowners like me so what has he had to
do his Mexican yard workers with their
very meager English speaking skills are
unable to communicate with their
business clients so he has hired a whole
cadre of native-born American Americans
barely out of high school to accompany
each of these Mexican teams on every job
these American kids don't have to do
very much except oversee the Mexicans
and talk to the client when the need
arises yet their supervisory role
commands they're much better wages than
if they had been pulling weeds if Jacob
couldn't hire cheap Mexican labor it
would mean that he would just pay
American Americans more as restriction
is sometimes claimed no it would mean
that his business just couldn't get off
the ground because he wouldn't be able
to offer the service at a price that
would be a
portable to people like me I'd have to
either give up on my nice yard or I
would have to take fewer writing
assignments and do yard work which
actually might pay me a little better
but either way there would be a net
attrition in economic activity and
productivity losses so there are three
broad lessons from my story each one of
which is borne out by academic
literature first the most obvious one is
that no one disputes that most Americans
like me are not competitors but
customers of low-skilled immigrants
immigrant presence therefore increases
our real wages as goods and services
become cheaper allowing us to buy more
income with more products with the same
income it also boosts our productivity
by allowing us to use our time and time
on tasks that are better suited for our
natural abilities and that produce
better returns for us second more
low-skilled immigration does not mean
fewer jobs for native-born because
immigrants because jobs are not a
Malthusian zero-sum game just like
jacob's Mexican workforce they're
cheaper rates expand the market for
these services in this way
immigrants create the jobs that they
have they don't snatch them from others
their presence allows more businesses to
form creating better paying jobs for
Americans as well the only economist who
has found significant displacement of
natives by low-skilled immigrants in
America is Bor Hass and that's because
he assumes far greater substitutability
among them than is warranted in reality
immigration immigrant inflows tracked
labor market logic so that immigrant
skills complement those of label off net
the native-born they don't really
compete with them
third and the third lesson of this is
not only do immigrants not cost
Americans jobs they don't threat
American wages either that's the other
big claim again that's a rap against
low-skilled immigrants that's because
their presence allows natives such as
jacob's american supervisors to exploit
their language and communication skills
where they real competitive advantage
lies now restriction estar gyu that you
know simple supply and demand economics
101 would dictate as the supply of
immigrant labor increases overall wages
decrease and bore Hass has examined this
impact of diminishing wages on various
native native groups by education level
in this very gloomily titled paper
called the labor demand curve is
downward-sloping he found that in that
but even he found that the net overall
impact on American wages as well as on
every cohort of American there was a
short-run downward impact in the long
run however the overall impact was
actually zero could I have the slide
please
only one group high school dropouts felt
any said any noticeable and lasting
negative impact according to actually a
very nifty little chart of Boris's own
findings that Brian Kaplan of George
Mason University has prepared and if you
look at this chart look at the long-run
wage effects and the short-run wage
effects and you will see that on the
long-run wage effects there's only one
group college graduates that have any
noticeable long-run impact in the short
run I'm sorry in the long run that's the
only negative impact in the short run
there are more negative impacts but
there is subsequent paper by Perry and
ottaviano who used both houses kind of
data national level data and they
couldn't actually corroborate even the
short run impact on wages that board has
found and and as for the native the the
the high school dropouts they found that
in the long run there was a positive
effect even on their wages although in
the short run they found a very small
point three percent negative return
now one big reason why Bohr Haas
findings it seems have been wrong is
because he made this Malthusian
assumption that capital capital wouldn't
adjust much in response to the greater
availability of immigrant labor in other
words his model essentially took the
existing amount of capital and divided
it among the greater number of workers
and so you got lower wages but the fact
of the matter is as employers save more
they generate more profits more profit
accumulates more capital accumulates and
the labor capital ratio is restored very
very quickly
so in summary open immigration policies
are a win for immigrants who can escape
poverty they are a win for native
consumers of immigrant services whose
real wages go up and they're a win for
for immigrant for native workers whose
productivity goes up although there
might be some pockets of losers here and
there so let me consider one powerful
objection that immigration forced make
to open borders that even Milton
Friedman conceded was a problem and
that's namely the existence of the
welfare state
you know if restriction is there you
know people who opposed to immigration
would say open borders are fine if we
didn't have the welfare state but with
the welfare state they are a problem and
essentially because what the welfare
state does is that by allowing employers
to not pay immigrants enough for their
needs because immigrants can fulfill
these needs in the welfare state through
the welfare state they're essentially
privatizing their profits but they are
socializing the costs on everybody else
so that's the big argument and and if
you socialize the cost of something then
you know that's not economically good
now unlike the economic benefits of
immigration the fiscal impact of
immigration due to the welfare state is
actually it is quite contested and there
have been studies produced by CIS and
fair and the Heritage Foundation that
show that low-skilled that immigrants
actually you know do cost the country
something but one of the problems when
these studies and I have a greater a
camp occur a longer account
thus in my actual pace paper is that
they don't do a full cross-generational
accounting of the costs and benefits of
immigrants so if they caught they they
count as costs for instance the cost of
educating the children of immigrants but
then they don't take into consideration
their taxes that these children pays
after they grow up there would be reason
to worry about more open immigration
policies if immigrants were actually
coming to this country for welfare that
would be the kind of thing that the
founders would worry about but there is
really no evidence of that not only is
labor participation rate of foreign men
much higher than a native men native men
but for unauthorized unskilled laborers
it is even higher it's it's to the
extent it's 94% I mean that's really
very high and Cato Institute's Dan
Griswold has done a study and found that
actually immigrants tend to flock
low-skilled immigrants even tend to
flock to States with low social spending
not high social spending but of course
this you know immigrants can go to
states with low social spending but that
doesn't mean that they are still not
consuming more in welfare services than
they are paying in taxes so what is the
fiscal impact of immigration now no one
disputes that high-skilled immigrants
are actually on the whole they
contribute more than they take away the
National Research Council in 1996 did
the most comprehensive study that
anybody has ever done and they found
that high-skilled immigrants on the
whole along with their descendants
represent a hundred and ninety eight
thousand fiscal gain for the country
with low-skilled immigrants they found
that they represent a $13,000 fiscal
loss they and their descendants so
that's over a period of many many years
this figure is pretty small but it would
be even smaller now because recall that
the study was conducted before the
immigration reform Act of 1996 when
immigrants both legal and illegal were
barred from our most means-tested
federal benefits so in other words
immigration on the whole is a fiscal
plus high-skilled immigrants are a
fiscals
low-skilled immigrants are a negative
but a very small negative but now factor
in the economic contributions of
low-skilled immigrants and the picture
fundamentally changes now also bear in
mind that when we are talking these days
about you know the the social costs of a
low-skilled immigrants essentially we
are talking about the cost of education
their children through public schools
and for their emergency care now setting
aside emergency care for a little while
but public's une middle-income family
American family with three children
would be a net fiscal drag so you can do
a snapshot in time analysis of a lot of
Americans and find out that there are
periods in their life when they are a
burden or net burden but that would of
course be a very misleading picture
because even because even with public
schools education is still an investment
public schools are a very inefficient
form of investment yet they are some
kind of an investment and so the bottom
line is that ultimately even if you
subtract the fiscal costs of low-skilled
immigrants on the whole they are an
economic plus and Texas actually has
done one of the most comprehensive
studies of this the Texas Comptroller in
2006 found that illegal immigrants cost
the state five hundred and four million
dollars annually but they actually
produce economic benefits to the tune of
seventeen point seven billion dollars so
that's the math one final point
restriction is talk about the fiscal
cost of letting immigrants in but rarely
about the fiscal costs of keeping them
out as if their own policies are
costless but the fact is that a
restriction ism is pricey both in
monetary terms and to our liberties the
building and maintenance cost of 700
miles fence in the 2000 mile Mexican
border
not counting labor costs or the costs of
acquiring land would be about 50 billion
dollars over 25 years in addition we
would need border control agents and
drones and other costly paraphernalia
like courts and prisons but the biggest
price of restriction ISM is in lost
liberties indeed to keep willing foreign
workers away from willing American
employers requires not just barred
fences and border dogs against the
immigrants it also requires a crackdown
on American employers some states are
now requiring employers to participate
in Iver off' I and pay one hundred and
fifty dollars to verify the immigrant
immigrant status status of every
potential recruit where the foreigner or
American with the federal government
this is essentially a hidden tax on
employment and to make sure that
business is paid Arizona and Alabama are
resorting to ever more draconian
business death penalties that revoke the
license of any employer who is caught
twice with an illegal in their employee
so essentially the logic is they're
shutting down American businesses to
protect American workers treating
foreign workers like Malthusian mouths
will put Americans on the road to
serfdom economic growth will be just one
thing that'll get trampled along the way
our third speaker is mr. Mark Krikorian
mr. Kerkorian has served as executive
director of the Center for Immigration
Studies since 1995 the center examines
and critiques the impact of immigration
on the United States he frequently
testifies before Congress and has
published articles in numerous outlets
including the Washington Post the New
York Times the Los Angeles Times and
commentary he is a contributor at
National Review Online and has appeared
on 60 minutes Nightline
the news hour with Jim Lehrer CNN and
NPR he is the author of two books the
new case against immigration both legal
and illegal and how Obama is
transforming America through immigration
mr. Krekorian holds a master's degree
from the Fletcher School of Law and
Diplomacy and a bachelor's degree from
Georgetown University he also spent two
years at you ever
excuse me Yerevan State University in
the then Soviet Armenia the title of his
address is the economic case for
limiting immigration mark Krikorian
thank you Ron I forgot my Karl Marx pin
instead because we're in Texas I'm
wearing my come and get it flag pin from
Gonzales in the Texas Revolution you're
free to read my Marxist ravings at
national review calm or at the Center
for Immigration Studies website CIS org
that can be a resource I think for a lot
of you who are teaching we just released
a very large compendium of immigration
statistics looking at the most recent
data and and really going into the
hundred pages of everything you could
imagine except shoe sizes now we're
considering here whether immigration
whether there's an economic case for
open borders in immigration I'll be
happy in the qat to talk about the
relative merits of some particular visa
program or whether illegal immigrants
brought here as minors should get green
should get green cards but what we're
talking about here is specifically what
are the economic consequences of lifting
controls on the settlement of foreigners
in the United States to re-emphasize
something Ken had said which I'll cut
short in my comments here open borders
as an ideological principle as a moral
imperative as it is presented by some of
the more Jacobin libertarians is
fundamentally contrary to the very
concept of self-government if we the
people do not have the authority to
decide how many people which people on
what terms are allowed to enter our
country in what sense can our political
community be described as sovereign that
having been said unlimited immigration
might nonetheless be a policy choice
that the elected representatives of the
people might want to make and in that
light let's look at the economic
consequences of unlimited immigration
first and briefly there's no question
that the first effect is that it
increases the aggregate size of the
economy this is kind of obvious but I
bring it up only because many of the
advocacy reports
state-based Chambers of Commerce and
others release about trying to get state
legislators and congressmen and others
to embrace the wonderfulness of
unlimited immigration are based on this
idea that immigration makes the economy
bigger there's no question that it does
we're probably our GDP is a 1 trillion
dollars maybe more larger because of the
40 million immigrants in the United
States but a larger economy certainly
doesn't necessarily mean a a better
economy just as an example obvious again
this is going to be obvious to most of
you Canada and Indonesia have roughly
similar sized economies no one would say
that the average Indonesian is as rich
or as well-off as the average Canadian
because there's so many more Indonesians
so then the second consideration is how
much do native-born Americans benefit
from immigration in fact that seems to
me the only real yardstick for assessing
government policies and there's a
standard way of calculating the benefit
from immigration the immigrant surplus
which the National Academy of Sciences
used President Bush's counsel and
economic advisors also estimated and to
cut to the quick the point is that there
is in fact a net gain from immigration
something like one-quarter of 1% of GDP
roughly safe with 15 trillion dollar GDP
forty billion dollar gain now that comes
from reducing the wages of American
workers by some four hundred and twenty
billion dollars but generating four
hundred and sixty four hundred sixty
billion dollars in benefit for those who
do not compete with America with
immigrant workers and in fact immigrants
are a substitute for American workers
they're not the kind of workers that
immigrants substitute for are the kind
of workers that none of us work
with or no or probably are related to
nonetheless there are enormous numbers
of less skilled Americans and young
Americans who compete directly with
immigrant workers so in a sense
immigration serves as a government
created vehicle for redistribution of
wealth from high school dropout
Americans to better educated Americans
and business owners
so essentially policymakers have a have
to face a moral question is it just to
reduce the wages of native-born less
skilled workers and teenagers and other
people who are in competition with
immigrant workers in order to increase
the wages of lawyers journalists and
business owners guess how that turns out
one final point in this respect is worth
making there's no question that
immigration has significantly increased
the supply of workers in occupations
that require less education there uh
ously some highly skilled occupations
that have large concentrations of
immigrants as well nonetheless
immigration has had its largest impact
on non-supervisory occupations in food
service construction childcare
agriculture building cleaning and
maintenance and light manufacturing of
course is also widespread agreement that
over the past three decades
just as immigration has increased
enormously these occupations and the
less educated workers who fill those
occupations have seen a significant
decline in the real wages and a very
large decline relative to college
graduates real wages for male high
school dropouts have declined 22% since
the late 1970s and for high school male
high school graduates real wages are
down 10%
no doubt there are other factors that
are contributing to that decline in
wages for low-skilled work
but such a decline is certainly what we
would expect if immigration was
adversely impacting blue-collar American
workers so let me come to the third
economic concern about unlimited
immigration it increases the size of the
economy it creates a small net benefit
by driving down the wages of the poor
the third aspect is the effect of
immigration on government spending
government now spends a far larger share
of national income than during prior
wage waves of immigration it's not
really that the immigrants are all that
different from a century ago they're
really not but the conditions into which
they come are very different government
now spends something like 40% of GDP now
we all hope that's gonna go down I'm
keeping my fingers crossed I'm knocking
doors for Romney I don't know how much
good that's gonna do nonetheless the
basic reality of a large state spent
using taxpayer money to spend a very
large share of national income is not
going away the problems the the problem
is summed up by Milton Friedman quote
it's just obvious that you can't have
immigration and a welfare state unquote
mass immigration much less completely
open immigration will inevitably top be
dominated by less educated less skilled
by the poor importing millions of poor
people with large families as we've been
doing for several decades means that by
definition they will pay relatively
little in taxes and they will make heavy
use of government services this is true
not because of any moral defect in the
immigrants is not because of laziness
it's not because there's even that many
people conniving abroad to come here and
get on TANF it's because times have
changed and in our modern society 19th
century-style immigrant is not going to
is going to earn wages low enough to
qualify for a whole variety of
government services
in fact even without open borders under
our current immigration system which
admits about 1.1 million legal
immigrants each year plus several
hundred thousand illegal immigrants we
have imported a poverty class that is
supported by tax payers in 2010
immigrants and their young children
accounted for one in four persons in
poverty when you look at what is called
in or near poverty which is 200% of the
poverty level or less which is the
threshold for many means-tested
government programs you see that nearly
half of immigrants and their young
children are in or near poverty two
thirds of Mexican immigrants are in or
near poverty Mexican immigrants being by
far the largest immigrant group
equivalent to the next ten combined
as a result of these low incomes
immigrants pay relatively less in taxes
of course and make relatively greater
use of welfare among all immigrant
households in again in 2010 36% receive
at least one means-tested government
benefit among immigrant households from
Latin America 50% use welfare and among
Mexican immigrants again by far the
largest immigrant group in the country
57% use at least one welfare program now
some might reply that the solution is to
end welfare and shrink the state this is
this is this is usually put as the
immigration see welfare know is how it's
often put well I'll make a deal with
those people who believe that abolish
welfare abolish Medicare abolish public
education totally privatize Social
Security then give me a call and we'll
talk about immigration but even Nobel
prize-winning economist Gary Becker
understands that's not going to happen
he preferred he's written that he would
clearly prefer a system of totally free
movement of labor totally open borders
but as he's written quote experience
demonstrates that in our political
system it is impossible to prevent
immigrants even those here illegally to
gain access to those benefits I believe
that with unlimited immigration many
would come mainly because they are
attracted by these government benefits
and they would then be voting to
influence future government spending and
other public policies end quote and that
brings me to my fourth point about the
economics of open immigration and that
is that even high levels of immigration
now under our limited system much less
open immigration reshapes the political
and social environment in ways that
undermine free enterprise and economic
dynamism the leftist understand this
perfectly well and they've been quite
open about the transformative effects
of unlimited immigration Eliseo Medina I
don't know how many of you may be
familiar with him he's the vice
president of the SEIU the hard left
labor union Service Employees
International Union and by the way is
honorary chairman of the Democratic
socialists of America so they're not
even hiding it said this at a left-wing
gathering the progressive community
needs to solidly be on the side of
immigrants they will solidify and expand
the progressive coalition for the future
we will create a governing coalition for
the long term not just for an election
cycle he knows what he's talking about I
think now there are two aspects of this
transformative effect of mass
immigration the first is as the quote by
Medina suggests that it imports voters
this is what Becker pointed to as well
who will back status to big government
politicians and policies with the
inevitable baleful consequences for
economic growth and dynamism secondly
though and more deeply and permanently
mass immigration changes American
society in ways that make statist
solution more attractive to voters at
large expanding the transformative
effect beyond merely immigrant voters to
voters who aren't even thinking about
immigration first votes to exaggerate
only a little
the left's immigration strategy is to
replace the American electorate with one
that's more receptive to statism over
all new immigrants are voting sixty to
eighty percent in favor of Democrats not
just Hispanic immigrants but Asian
African middle-eastern even European
immigrants vote Democrat now over time
the political preferences of immigrant
groups can in fact change assimilation
does translate into voting behavior
that's more similar to the rest of the
American public but this is a very long
multi-generational process one that has
been accelerated in the past by pauses
in immigration to allow the body politic
if you will to digest the new
populations
now one of the reasons for this is the
outsider status inherent to immigrants
just inherent to the process of
immigration which attracts them to the
party of the pluribus as opposed to the
unum meaning the Democrats as opposed to
the Republicans in addition though there
are specific aspects of today's
immigration that make it easy for the
status left to garner the lion's share
of the immigrant vote for one thing a
large majority of immigrants are
considered minorities under our current
race laws and thus will benefit from
race specific policies such as
affirmative action quotas minority set
asides the left is the defender and
promoter of such policies again get rid
of it then come back and talk to me it's
a hill where we've been expending
Herculean efforts to try to limit the
racialization of society so far with not
much effect you simply cannot keep
importing huge numbers of foreigners who
the day they step off the plane or off
the bus are eligible for preferences
over American workers furthermore
American immigrants and their children
disproportionately vote for the left
because they are disproportionately poor
as I mentioned before and those living
in or near poverty pay very little in
taxes now I'm not gonna make governor
Romney's mistake and talk about 47%
voting the wrong way but nonetheless the
small government message of lower taxes
and slimmed down government simply is
not going to resonate with people who
aren't paying a lot in taxes and who
also are used in making very high use of
government programs they are going to
inevitably and naturally be attracted to
parties to the party that wants more
government programs and is not
interested in cutting taxes of course
many immigrants don't vote either
because they're not citizens or they
simply choose not to but their children
are much more likely to vote and among
the children and grandchildren of
immigrants we see trends disturbing
trends that also point to some
port for statist solution of statist
government in addition to poverty and
welfare use for instance shockingly 50%
of births to native-born hispanic women
these are the daughters and
granddaughters of earlier immigrants are
illegitimate also the research is clear
that being married is one of the key
indicators of voting Republican but only
52% of native-born Hispanics between 25
and 65 again the children and
grandchildren of immigrants largely are
married compared to more than two-thirds
of native-born whites which itself is
probably a low number but again that
points to social problems that we face
as a people but that immigrants face
more seriously low incomes welfare use
and family breakdown are only part of
the problem
almost all immigrants as Kennedy
mentioned come from cultures that do not
have a deep tradition of limited
government to put it mildly
this makes the left's approach of
creating a patron client relationship
between the immigrant and the state much
more attractive more natural to them too
many immigrants in contrast to the
rights approach of trying to of
generating and fostering a self-reliant
citizenry that will hold government
accountable but the electoral
preferences of immigrants of immigrant
voters are really only part of the story
perhaps even more important is the fact
that immigration creates a political
social and economic environment more
favorable to the left political
scientist Fredo arias King itself
Mexican by the way has written that
quote immigration is a source of power
for the eight artists left the status
left not so much because immigrants tend
to vote for the party most associated
with them but because the consequences
of immigration from poor countries
fundamentally reinforces their argument
for state intervention in other words
immigration transforms American society
in
that make native-born Americans who
aren't even thinking about immigration
more receptive to the big government
solutions of the left just one example
of this this is you see this in many
policy areas let's just look at the
issue of health insurance nearly
one-third of all uninsured people in the
United States are immigrants or the
young children of immigrants and
immigration is responsible for
two-thirds of the growth in the number
of uninsured over the past decade would
the push for increased government
involvement in health care have had as
much resonance with non immigrant voters
if immigration had not increased the
seeming urgency of the problem
immigration also increases income
inequality significantly both by adding
to the number of low-income people
through immigration and by lowering the
wages of Americans at the bottom rungs
of the labor market as a result again
calls for income redistribution and more
social programs to address these
problems are heard more sympathetically
by native-born voters even if they're
not poor themselves and aren't even
thinking about immigration as an issue
finally immigration increases support by
for big government by artificially
increasing society's diversity a growing
body of research pioneered by Harvard's
Robert Putnam of Bowling Alone Fame
shows that increased diversity results
in a loss of civic engagement not just
between groups where different ethnic
and other groups don't interact as much
but even within groups immigration
driven diversity means everyone in
society is progressively less trusting
less involved in civic life less likely
to attend church less likely to join the
Masons Hadassah the PTA less likely even
to have friends over for dinner and
while this is undesirable in itself what
it means politically is that immigration
contributes to the progressive weakening
of what Edmund Burke called the little
platoons of society yielding more and
more public space to the state thus
lending increasing credence to the
arguments offered by the party of more
and
government to finish there's the old
joke about the economists stranded on a
desert island with only a can of beans
and no way to get to the beans and so
what he does is he assumes a can opener
well open borders belongs to the assumed
a can opener part of economics it can be
interesting and useful as a thought
experiment but it's place is in the
sophomore year dormitory bull session
not in serious considerations of
government policy thank you so we have
about 15 minutes for your questions and
again please raise your hand and state
your name I'll wait for the microphone
to come to you before asking your
question and then please address your
question to a particular member of the
panel thank you yeah my name is Brad
Bailey I'm thank you for having me today
a great panel question now the federal
government is not good at picking
winners and losers only market can do
that I believe so we saw that pretty
clearly with Solyndra where the
government chose a loser and it cost our
economy a lot of money why then should
the federal government pick out which
immigrants should be allowed to come to
America should we let the free market
decide that and have minimal control
regulations maybe states rights I'm a
restaurant owner here I employ a lot of
those people that you call the unskilled
group I can tell you people that work in
our tea restaurants here in Houston
Texas aren't what you just described in
your manifesto they're mr. Kevorkian
States local governments understand the
needs of their businesses a lot more
than the federal government does our
current system is broken 110 percent
broken but it's hurting businesses
because it's so broken let's return to
the states the state of Texas for
example can run a much better economy
than the federal government
thank you if Texas returns regains its
independence that might be true
the reason states can't cannot have
their own immigration policies is
because there's nothing keeping you from
moving from one state to another Tom
Vilsack the AG secretary who was
governor of Iowa a a number of years ago
when he was governor said we should have
a Iowa only immigration policy let
people move to Iowa and let more people
in if they promise to move to Iowa if
people to leave in Iowa because of the
weather or because of jobs or what have
you what makes you think immigrants are
any different and what would stop them
from just get on a bus and going to
California or to Florida after once they
got into Iowa so the idea of a
state-based immigration policy is just a
non-starter it cannot work in an
environment where people can move from
state to state as far as the your point
about picking winners and losers I think
you're right I much of the actually
existing immigration system is absurdly
bureaucratic and based on kind of
ridiculous social planning kind of
concepts you know the government can do
a labor market test accurately collect
that information process it and act on
it in time for it to mean anything I
think all of that stuff is nonsense and
now if you want to argue safe for some
kind of a some kind of system where you
bid for immigrant visas or you sell
immigrant visas again I mean I'm not I
don't know if that's a good idea but
that's worth exploring but nonetheless
we end up you the basic concept of the
state limiting immigration is key
because if we adopt what President Bush
in 2004 January 2004 his big speech that
he made on immigration if we adopt that
approach which was the formulation was
any willing worker can come to work for
any willing employer this is essentially
the kind of open borders that chica was
talk
about you have lost control of your
polity the idea that this is not going
to have harmful effects the idea that
this is not going to create the kind of
problems for tax payers and the kind of
political problems I referred to as a
fantasy and the only way supporters of
that kind of approach escape that proper
to escape that reality is to say well
we'll let them in but we won't let them
be citizens they'll only be temporary
workers and they'll leave when they're
done sorry but all of human history
shows that there's nothing as permanent
as a temporary worker the very illegal
immigration crisis we are facing today
is the result of the bracero program
which was a temporary worker program
from the 40s to the 60s that created the
network's the momentum that we're still
experiencing from illegal from with
illegal immigration so I mean I am
completely sympathetic with the idea
that we have a very badly constructed
immigration system and in fact I lay out
in a little more detail the way I think
it ought to be reformed it's in the
final chapter of my book on Amazon I
think it's a it's in the digital
remainder bin at Amazon I'm afraid so
you can pick it up cheap but but I mean
I agree with you that the system is
poorly put together the answer is not to
simply let in anybody that anybody wants
to hire Corian is actually being too coy
over here he does have a solution to the
kinds of bureaucratic hassles that
you're talking about that immigrants
encounter his solution is to actually
just stop all immigration I mean he's
pretty explicit about that he wants no
high-skilled and he wants no low-skilled
immigration he wants a moratorium on
immigration and what that'll do to
business is like you and what it'll do
to the economy one can only you know
fantasize about that and I suppose
sophomoric dorms it's not something that
should be admitted company but you face
that day in and day out as for the bar
cero program that mr. Krekorian was
talking about actually
if anything proves that emigrate
temporary a generous guest worker
program would work beautifully in this
country it's actually the bar cero
program the entire problem of illegal
immigration was created after that
program ended and the reason was at that
time with the bar cero program there was
essentially a very easy way for
employers like you to get visas for you
know Mexican Mexican workers and they
could come and go with the seasons so
American far farm jobs during summer in
California you would have a huge influx
of the Mexican population that would go
back to their country at the end of the
at the end of the season because they
could get a visa to reenter the country
when they wanted to essentially by
eliminating that guest worker program it
made it very risky and costly for these
cross-border flows to happen with the
result that the people who come here now
stay here because if they were to go
back they would have to pay smugglers
fees they would have to risk crossing a
huge desert you know possibly dying in
the process so they just stay over here
so you know this very cute line there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
worker visa but that's because of the
way our laws are constructed that
restrict mobility we've had a very very
successful program with the barceló
program by the way which ended because
of Union opposition unions were opposed
to the competition that cheap Mexican
labor presented that was the problem
that's why it ended if I could respond
first of all I have never used ever the
word moratorium I like I'll give you the
very brief version of the last chapter
of my book which you can read in more
detail when you buy it my point is and
the the basic point of my policy
prescriptions is that a modern society
doesn't need any immigration but that
doesn't mean zero immigration that means
zero based budgeting in immigration we
start at zero and then decide which
specific categories of immigration are
so compelling that we admit them
regardless of the
and high scale immigration can cause and
that would be number one spouses and
little children of US citizens that's
three hundred fifty to four hundred
thousand people a year right off the bat
secondly a handful of genuine Einsteins
the best and brightest that we have
categories for now but even they are
bureaucratic and then we admit lots of
people who don't fit that bill I
actually have recommended in the book
half tongue half in cheek that we just
give people a IQ test in English and if
you get a hundred and forty we let you
in and if you don't you don't
because tying workers to jobs as this
willing worker willing employer model
would have it is just a recipe for
indentured servitude and then thirdly
some modest number of genuine refugees
who will never have anywhere else to go
that adds up to you know we're talking
four hundred four maybe five hundred
thousand people a year half of what we
take now that's not no immigration it's
but it's much less immigration and will
mean one comment on the bracero program
there's this idea that there's no that
we now have a ratchet effect because
people can't just come and go from
Mexico freely that they're coming and
staying the data shows in fact that the
percentage of people from Mexico coming
to the United States and then going back
has been going down it's been declining
there's no question about that but it's
been declining since they started
collecting data it is nothing to do with
enforcement it has to do with the
movement of rural people in Mexico into
urban areas it's something that's
happened in every country in the world
as it's developed it's just that because
of our cockamamie immigration policies a
very large share of Mexico's rural
population is moving to our cities
permanently instead of moving to
Mexico's own cities permanently
yes George Celgene the University of
Georgia first of all up I wanted to say
to mr. Krekorian I'm glad to know that
you don't think the government is good
at picking winners and losers I wish you
weren't so confident in your own ability
to do so my question is my question is
has to do with your remarks concerning
how immigration has tended to depress
wages in the blue collar industries but
it seems to me that many of those
industries are precisely the ones that
are in danger of failing as a result of
foreign competition or that have been
surviving by means of outsourcing or
simply leaving to relocate in foreign
countries allowing for those
alternatives rather than just the
possibility that keeping immigrants out
will raise the keep the wage rates of
existing workers high is it really
possible confidently to declare that
holding immigration down will ultimately
make workers existing US workers better
off the answer is yes and the reason is
that a very large share of the
occupations of the jobs that we are
importing immigrants to do cannot be
traded you can't import housing from
China you can't import restaurants from
Bangladesh you can't import office
cleaning from Nigeria now there are some
things you can import and I'm actually I
like trade but I'd rush much rather
import the product of the labor of a
Mexican worker than importing the
Mexican worker himself because importing
a worker changes your society
fundamentally because he is now because
he's a human being he is not simply a
labor input workers are not just labor
inputs whereas the product the congealed
prod
to their labor in a shirt that we import
or a pair of shoes or what have you is
an inanimate thing that we can dispense
with and doesn't change our society in
any way there is a fundamental moral
difference between importing the foreign
worker and importing the product made by
that foreign worker and I'm actually
happy to import the product made by the
foreign worker I don't want to import
the worker himself we have time for one
final question
hi Jamison Taylor I want to thank both
of you in particular seek a mark for the
work that you do and I respect the work
that you'll do I'm an economics question
but I want to preface it by just
wondering whether or not we can even
answer this question fully by just
talking about economics in spite of the
fact that that's the theme of the talk
and Kevin I think kind of touched on
that you touched on some of that as well
mark and talking about some of the costs
of immigration that we don't usually
think about when we think about
immigration my economics question is
though it seems like you guys are using
some very different numbers to get at
the economic costs of immigration I
think that's the case because it's
extremely difficult to actually quantify
the costs the costs are very very broad
just as just as people are a great
resource people also bring about lots of
different problems that we can't fully
anticipate so I'm wondering if we can
just look at one study for instance the
report that the Texas Comptroller did
would you guys be comfortable commenting
on the pros and cons of that study mark
for instance why he thinks deficient
Sica why you think that it's a
methodological sound study no I couldn't
do that yeah it would be hard for me to
do it from memory to I think the
National Research Council study the 1996
study which looked just at the you know
the welfare costs the fiscal costs of
immigrants that's a better study that
both sides actually referred to and you
know you can look at I mean that you
know that I think that's what's not that
hard is to assess the costs of
immigrants what is much harder harder is
to assess the benefits of immigrants
because they are so intangible so by and
large my impression is that the benefits
of immigrants are are largely
undercounted or they are underestimated
whereas there is a tendency to
exaggerate their cost and the Texas
Comptroller study actually did a very
good job of trying to balance both sides
out in the National Research Council
study what they did very well was that
they looked at the cross generational
costs of immigrants so they looked at
not just the you know the investment
public investment in the in immigrants
at any moment but then what the returns
of those investments were when their
children started paying off now the
market Corian site basically stops at
the analysis that the NRC did in terms
of the costs that the first-generation
immigrants use and then doesn't look at
the rest of it but actually if you look
at that entire study I think that's a
pretty good benchmark to think about
this whole issue of the cost of
immigration the reason I actually don't
think that the parts of the National
Research Council study of costs that
project into the future are kind of
dubious is first of all they're
projecting 300 years into the future to
figure out the cost and benefits we're
talking you know the tax is paid by
Captain Kirk literally and also its they
make all kinds of assumptions about when
the ballot the budget will be balanced
and there'll be a deal in a particular
year in 2020 something or other made by
Congress I mean a lot of it is kind of
fanciful I would just leave you with
this thought if low-skilled immigrants
are so great for the economy why are we
spending so much effort in educating our
own workers the National Education
Association could do a great job of
turning out high school dropouts why
import more of them what can I get out
of Spawn do that
look actually let me respond to that
which is that you know protectionism
doesn't work when it is applied in trade
and protectionism doesn't work when it
is applied to labor I come from Detroit
where American automakers you know at a
at a time they were they were asked they
were great deal of protectionism against
Japanese car makers they had two
Japanese car makers like Toyota and
Honda had to agree to voluntarily sell
fewer cars in America because our
American companies couldn't compete what
was the option top up short of that the
upshot of that was that our car
companies became globally less
competitive we just couldn't make
products that were good enough to sell
abroad the same thing happens when you
protect labor one of the up shots of
letting low-skilled workers from Mexico
into the country is that has induced our
America our native-born American
children to acquire the skills to move
on to the higher rungs of the job ladder
so with the result there is a greater
incentive for them to actually finish
school because they can't simply count
on that plumbing job or that weed
pulling job and if you look at the
statistics and I would point you to a
very very good paper that Dan Griswold
of Cato Institute did which was
basically made the case as Mexican
workers have moved into the so-called
underclass in America the American
workers have actually moved into the
middle class and there is a very very
big correlation just to give you one
statistic from there between 1995 and
2004 the number of families living under
the official poverty level fell from 8
18.1 million to 7.6 million in America
immigrant household poverty rose by one
hundred and ninety four thousand but the
native households that were in poverty
decreased by six hundred and seventy
five thousand so that's what immigrants
are doing they are basically doing
low-skilled jobs and allowing Americans
to move to the middle class okay
there's one thing that's very clear two
things one is the debate will continue
although number two you never want to be
the person that stands between a big
audience and lunch and that happens to
be us please join me in thanking our
panel